IMAN VELLANI
Ms. Marvel, baby.
MATT LINTZ
This is my shot.
ADIL EL ARBI
Here on the set of Ms. Marvel.
SANA AMANAT
Our actors can do everything.
MATT LINTZ
I feel exhilarated.
SAAGAR SHAIKH
I think I'm doing it.
I'm trying to channel so much energy.
SANA AMANAT
We go from a dance sequence...
[Cheering]
SANA AMANAT
...to a fight sequence
in a matter of 24 hours.
RISH SHAH
That was fun!
ADIL EL ARBI
There's so much chemistry
we feel that they're really like family.
YASMEEN FLETCHER
It feels like I have known them
like my whole life.
This has been insane,
but I wouldn't trade it.
IMAN VELLANI
And we're high fiving in
slow motion...
BILLAL FALLAH
It feels like there is this
new generation coming up.
♪♪
IMAN VELLANI
Why you gotta make me laugh so much?
[Laughing]
SANA AMANAT
Iman Vellani is truly
the heart of the show.
IMAN VELLANI
It's the greatest day of my life.
I was having so much fun
and I wanted to cherish
every single second of being there.
BISHA K. ALI
She's just very fundamentally lovable.
SANA AMANAT
It is just a testament of their talent.
We have something special.
Lightning in a bottle is the
best way to describe it.
ADIL EL ARBI
And...
IMAN VELLANI
Cut!